the former acting director of the cia
michael morrell he's come out and he's a
big big fan of bitcoin and blockchain
technology but it's not for the reason
that you think somebody who's involved
in the intelligence agencies or in law
enforcement of course they're trying to
catch bad people doing bad things and
that's exactly why they like bitcoin and
blockchain technology it's a public
ledger michael morrell here's a couple
of quotes from him where he explicitly
explains why he's so interested in these
technologies the first quote says based
on our research i have come to believe
that if there was one financial
ecosystem for bad actors to use that
would maximize law enforcement's chances
of identifying them and their illicit
activities it would be blockchain he
then goes on to describe if all
criminals used blockchain we could wipe
out illicit financial activity then he
goes on to describe some of his
important findings saying that they have
identified cases of laundering through
cryptocurrencies remaining relatively
small compared to the volume of cash
laundered through traditional methods he
also concluded that it is easier for law
enforcement to trace illicit activity
using bitcoin than it is to trace
cross-border illegal activity using
traditional banking transactions and far
easier than the cash transactions as
well and then lastly he states i pay you
two thousand dollars in a dark alley who
are the witnesses to that transaction
just you and me right with
cryptocurrency the whole world could be
the witness now of course every criminal
in the world every money launder every
drug dealer every nefarious actor their
choice currency for doing bad things is
still the us dollar and other fiat
currencies they can either use physical
cash which is nearly untraceable or they
can go through legacy banking systems
where the only way to get the
transaction history is if law
enforcement or intelligence agencies go
and ask a court to give them access with
bitcoin every single transaction is
written into a public ledger you don't
need a court order you don't need
anything else you simply can look right
on that actual public ledger and audit
it for yourself now of course i believe
in financial privacy just as much as
everybody else i don't like the fact
that all of a sudden everyone has access
to every transaction but that's what
makes bitcoin work that ultimately using
blockchain technology solve the double
spin problem there's many great teams in
the bitcoin ecosystem that are working
on increasing financial privacy and i'm
excited to see what they come up with
but at the end of the day criminals
don't want to use bitcoin because they
know their transactions are written into
that public blockchain and anyone in the
world forever can go back and look at
the transactions if you're a criminal
and you're using bitcoin to commit crime
you've got to be a first class idiot at
this point and so ultimately the acting
director of the cia from many years ago
coming out and saying that he
understands why bitcoin actually could
help solve or eliminate illicit activity
a lot of people aren't going to want to
listen to them but i think that everyone
should go and read this report because
ultimately michael morrow understands
exactly what law enforcement and
intelligence agencies are trying to do
when they look for bad people doing bad
things
and it's very clear that they realize
those bad people are using bitcoin it
increases the likelihood that they're
gonna get caught hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time